[Música]
huila que lindo aquí ya ve qué cosa más
bella mira cómo le va a ver a mi nombre
no es de la nada la abuela que iba a
venir pareciera que no pudo venir la
tuya me pidió ayuda a mí porque yo soy
emprendedora también me dijo que al
huila que organiza esta casa
probablemente no le importar un poquito
improvisación entonces para los que no
me conocen winona ryder rodríguez
alvarado wing yo soy de la chacarita
huila yo no he visto así todos los días
no crea abuelas que no se visten de
acuerdo a la ocasión porque vale la pena
sacarlo el chapo más lindo me da para
cuando cuando meditaba entonces vuela yo
le vengo a hablar un poquito lo que es
emprender ahora en la crisis civil hay
que echar palante that no hay que
marcarlo hard huila y entonces un
poquito para empezar con algo que nos
une a todos todos tenemos en común y las
puede que en el día anterior escuchó las
noticias vuelan los números alarmantes
del mundo acordarse que uno no puede
salir de la casa abuela y entonces uno
se queda pensando no se pregunta me baño
no me baño vuela es una pregunta válida
porque es que es un día a la vez que
aquí tomando la decisión porque de
sorprende el resto del día vea entonces
así es muy importante este acordarse que
todos estamos juntos
huila y es que yo le voy a decir a bueno
lo que está viviendo es una ansiedad no
es ganas de salir
huila repente uno dice si tan solo puede
ayudar al banco voy a hacer una fila
ojalá un banco del estado bede y
entonces no puede 1 huila porque no
puede salir o si no entonces usted se
acuerda de la cita que hace cinco años
no saco que tiene que ir a consulta
externa para que le dan las hemorroides
huila como que no es el momento o si no
entonces usted también allá el mes y al
rock y dijo que mi marido huila que
hombre más guapo pelo en pecho con
canasta un hombre guapísimo y entonces
mi marido me decía que le hace falta es
el evento sorpresa huila que llegue la
suegra sin avisar pero bueno huila
ahorita que avanzadas en verdad y
también ayer me cambia yo a la cédula
será que la podía renovar tampoco huila
no está no estaba vencida de la célula
entonces yo creo que todos estamos
viviendo esa ansiada en este momento yo
quiero pues proponerme a una idea que yo
tengo y la que yo creo que el ministro
no lo ha pensado sinceramente nadie con
todo el respeto y echarle un laxante al
agua para mí que se puede trabajar con
juegos de alcantarillado voy a hacer un
plan bien bueno grande la gente que no
ha sabido la casa
esto que cuando uno se toma un laxante
no puede salir entonces es una opción
para que la revisen ahí muy seriamente
yo creo que es una buena alternativa
para que la gente se quede en la casa
muy light y entonces ahora hablando
emprendimiento porque yo tengo familia
yo tengo que echar la muela delante y al
rockero que por supuesto es el sostén
vea el lugar pero pero no tiene que
ponerse creativo ya que ha pensado usted
que puede hacer ahora en la cuarentena y
huila ahora que está metido en la casa
que tiene más tiempo que podemos hacer
porque si yo no me eche alas y crítica
huila y la tengo un salud cuando me eche
a huila y si yo yo ese nombre lo había
habido pero para varón pero bueno era
huila entonces endometrio en salud para
la abuela y entonces huila uno ahora se
pone a pensar yo estaba viendo esa
opción del teletrabajo porque yo desde
el día 1 que yo lo escuché yo dije esto
como que es para mi vida entonces yo lo
que entiendo ahora es que uno de pelé y
entonces pagan ya es una idea ya
bastante conocida a huila pero lo que sí
he visto es que hay mucha gente
preparada hay mucha competencia y mucha
gente interesada pareciera pero eso sí
creo a la ministra que bien definiendo
como es el puesto y pongámosle si aún no
lo llamamos la amiga y entonces llama de
actuar y no videoconferencias volviendo
tele
dejando un trabajo no y así hay que ir
decidiendo un montón de carajadas yo me
he puesto a pensar así muy sinceramente
huila cuánto tiempo pongamos hay
jornadas de completado como en la
cargada porque yo sí le decirle logro en
media horita en la mañana verá era
mediodía leo las noticias lo que pasa
que como es hora pico yo no sé si pagan
menos y en la tarde-noche y yo me
acuesto temprano y dependiendo de cuánto
el marido no lo deje ver tele lo que
criticó un par de horitas tamiento yo
calculo huila que un medio tiempo lo que
yo le podría frenar la ministra pero sí
es importante porque pareciera que
creemos bastante grande will hay que hay
que hay que pensar bien cómo es esa cara
jada del teletrabajo porque yo lo que lo
que decía yo soy emprendedora yo soy
dueña el pollo alegre huila y entonces
todo lo que sea cocina comía con pollo
ya usted diga que diga qué es lo que se
le antoja joseba agua pero tú y yo estoy
renovando el menú ahora también huila y
entonces yo estoy lanzando relanzando
porque ya lo había hecho el arroz con
premio entonces pongamos carlos con
pollo bien éxito y huila pero yo le
mando alguna cara haitã algún detalle
digamos amables defendiéndose de una
gorila o un hombre a yo le echo un oscar
éticos le echo una candelita
desinfectado huila por eso no se
preocupe de antonio se le echo ahí para
que se entretenga durante el almuerzo y
tenga ideal como el elemento en sorpresa
que yo le decía y también ahora pensando
cosas que pueda ser un referente de alto
es se me vino una idea muy innovadora
huila que también parece que podría
podría funcionar verdad y es wind in its
yo lo estoy poniendo a disposición de la
gente puede empezar a utilizar este
servicio llama la censal y entonces ahí
pide lo que quieran de comer de garcía
de lo que yo sea cierto entonces usted
me llama y ya usted dice que lo que
quiere es el agua llegar hasta la casa y
entonces pongamos leer lo estoy
reclutando porque más bien con el
problema empleo que hay que medio que
quiera que le toque a uno vuela pero
echando pa lante que contratar a la
gente también cuando se puede entonces
estoy reclutando al y que de manera la
central reclutando al huila que que haya
hasta dejar entregaba en bicicleta en
moto a diego y la dependiendo de la
longitud de la distancia y entonces así
pues estoy contratando también will a
las cocineras de esos y casi que con un
casco de motocicleta porque no le
escupen la comida vea usted no se tiene
que preocupar por nada de eso pero
entonces yo les quería lanzar esta
innovación mía de algo que se me ocurrió
a mí así de la nada esas ideas que tiene
uno pero sí con todo este tema huila
tanto de que las conferencias de prensa
lo que me preocupa bien la caraja del
permiso sanitario huila vea yo le va a
ser muy sincera primero que hasta las
diez después que hasta las ocho después
que no cara hasta la 5 huila a qué hora
va a ir o no al baño explique meses o
huila porque yo no lo entendió muy bien
yo tengo muchas dudas con esa cara jada
no sé hay que respetarle a la directriz
de vila pero todos pongamos y ya las
cinco ya además terminó entonces que a
mediodía toque se rellenan a mí lo que
me preocupa sinceramente el roque que
ayer a la cárcel huila porque ese huila
del día y noche edad y es que qué hombre
más lindo vea yo acá es que me acuerdo y
me acuerdo cuando me propuso matrimonio
vila ya en el paso de los turistas se
agachó con un church y huila con ese
anillo calavera lo más lindo como
decirle qué novedad entonces yo no me
puedo imaginar que el huila mío se vaya
para la cárcel entonces tengo varias
dudas como yo le decía con el permiso
sanitario con amo les dé un permiso
diario o es cada vez
y entonces pongámosle yo como sirve la
todas las noches y entonces uno nunca
sabe vuela en la noche hay si va a estar
cerrado o adonde es que ya en alguno y
entonces pongámosle si a mí me dieron
permiso para hacerla número uno pero hay
una cosa lleva a la otra y entonces dice
que embarcada grima y como controlan esa
cara a quien vaya a ver a mí que no me
contraten verdad porque sinceramente
puedes con un tema verdad que yo creo
que vale la pena pues pues ponerse a
definir un poco más porque yo creo que
mucha gente en las mismas dudas con esa
cara del permiso sanitario y bueno
también en muchos otros emprendimientos
cuida que se le ocurren a uno yo estoy
dando clases de aeróbicos de las mañanas
y huila el otro semana a tener tutorial
de maquillaje y de moda huila porque
todo lo que sea el glamour ya no sería
conmigo y así de hay que ir pensando
huila yo no sé si usted está en su casa
haciendo nada de agua o haciendo más
bien demasiado viento pero hay que
pensar sobre las que oportunidad tengo y
grita en este momento para que usted
piense y cambie lo práctico y piensa de
con qué puede salir la caja para que
puede salir con una innovación como yo
vea cómo winglets
y huila ahora que viene la semana santa
me estuvieron llamando a mí para hacer
también de la mínima harían las
procesiones pero yo la hipocresía es así
qué novedad porque antes sí pero nunca
xavi todo hay que ser muy sincero y no
sentarse con hipocresía pero ya que la
semana santa piense usted apei la
táctica yo que le que le prenda el
bombillo voy a ver qué es lo que puede
hacer usted diferente y cómo podemos
ayudar en esta crisis está de mi parte
no sería todo ojalá los inspiren los los
ilumine los alegre el día de y muchas
gracias a todos y buenas tardes
[Música]